يبدو ان اسرائيل قتلت عددا كبيرا من
مواطنيها يوم السابع من اكتوبر فكيف حدث
ذلك بعد ترديد مسؤولين اسرائيليين وغربيين
كثيرا ان مقاتلي القسام ارتكبوا مجزره في
حفل موسيقي بمناطق غلاف غزه الشرطه
الاسرائيليه توصلت لمعلومات مغايره تماما
لهذه الروايه طائره حربيه اسرائيليه هي
التي قتلت المشاركين بمهر ان سوبرنوفا
اثناء محاولتها استهداف مسلحين على ما
يبدو التحقيقات الاوليه التي نشرت صحيفتها
اريتس مقتطفات منها اشارت الى ان مقاتلي
القسام لم يعرفوا مسبقا بوجود هذا الحفل
لكن مظليا واثناء عبورهم فوق مستوطنات
غلاف غزه شاهدوا اسرائيليين يخرجون ال
الشوارع قرب مستوطنه رعيم فابلغ عناصرهم
بذلك مقطع مسجل من احدى كاميرات مقاتلي
القسام اظهر طلبه من احد المحتجزين ارشاده
للذهاب الى هذه المستوطنه عندما وصل هؤلاء
المقاتلون الى المكان قصفته طائره
اسرائيليه مع المحتفلين بعد تلقيها
معلومات عن عمليات اسر فقتل اكثر من 360
شخصا حسب التحقيقات فان المروحيه الحربيه
انطلقت من قاعده راماد دافيد ويبدو ان
سيطره حماس على فرقه غزه وتعطل كل وسائل
التواصل بين الفرقه والاليه تسبب في حاله
ضياع لدى الجانب الاسرائيلي العثور على
جثث متفحمه قد يؤكد ما خلص اليه هذا
التحقيق اذ ان كتائب القسام لا تملك اسلحه
حارقه كنا نتحدث سابقا عن 1400 من الضحايه
لكن العدد الحقيقي كان 12 فقط بالغنا في
تقدير العدد كانت هناك جثث محترقه للغايه
وبالتالي فان طائره حربيه اسرائيليه هي
التي قتلت المحتفلين حسب محللين ما ينقض
سرديه اسرائيليه جديده بخصوص الجثث
المحترقه
m